i think that the internet is going to be
one of the major forces
for reducing the role of government
the one thing that's missing but that
will soon be developed
is a reliable e-cash
a method whereby on the internet you can
transfer funds
from a to b without a knowing b or b
knowing a
what is a bitcoin what is bitcoin what
backs a bitcoin you put some of your
money real money online and it turns
into bitcoin
i don't even know why we call them coins
except that they call it coins in a name
i think bitcoin is turned into a massive
multiplayer online game where
speculators are trying to out speculate
each other is it a a means of exchange
or an asset class i see you taking my
real dollars and
then you give me virtual money in return
thanksgiving dinner my grandmother asked
me what the heck is this bitcoin stuff
anyway right and i said do you remember
when visa cards first came out you were
used to paying with cash or with a check
and then a visa came out it was this
weird payment system that you didn't
understand
and she said yeah i remember that i said
well bitcoin is just the next evolution
of another payment system
[Music]
bitcoin by now you've probably heard of
it
the wild fluctuations in its price has
gained the attention of the mainstream
financial media
but bitcoin is much more than just your
average investment
beneath all the hype in hysteria lies
what could be the most important
technology of our lifetimes
so what exactly is it
to fully appreciate the characteristics
that make bitcoin a potentially
world-changing technology we first need
to understand what money is
currency started developing uh six to
nine thousand years ago some sort of
medium of exchange people used something
of value societies around the world
though started to select
gold and silver as their primary
currency about three thousand years ago
and then in about
680 bc
they became money when they were minted
into coins of equal weights
governments started creating
representative currencies where
you deposit your gold and silver or they
have gold and silver in the treasury and
they come out with notes that are
basically a claim check on the gold so
they're supposed to be as good as gold
because you can always convert them into
gold
throughout history precious metals were
chosen as money not through government
decree but because of their unique
features
gold is rare easily recognizable
portable durable and divisible above all
because gold is difficult to find and
labor intensive to mine refine and mint
it has always been perceived as a store
of value
[Music]
at bretton woods new hampshire delegates
from 44 allied and associate countries
arrived for the opening of the united
nations monetary and financial
conference
in modern history as world war ii was
coming to an end in 1944 the allied
nations met at the small town of breton
woods new hampshire
here they drafted a new financial system
which would stabilize the world's
financial system once the war ended
with the united states poised to enter a
golden age of prosperity the us dollar
was chosen to be the world's reserve
currency
the bretton wood system was created
after the second world war at the
bretton woods conference in new
hampshire
and rather than using gold as the means
of exchange between
countries as was the case under the old
gold standard the dollar was going to be
used and the dollar was chosen because
back then it was as good as gold
under this new system the countries of
the world would tie their currencies at
a fixed rate to the us dollar and
because most of the world's gold was
held in u.s vaults the us dollar would
be backed by gold at a fixed price of 35
dollars per ounce
this created a system where the
currencies of the world were effectively
backed by gold through the us dollar
i have directed secretary connelly to
suspend temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar into gold or other reserve
assets
the bretton woods system lasted for
about 25 years but in august of 1971
president richard nixon called for an
emergency press conference where he
announced foreign countries would no
longer be able to convert their us
dollar holdings into gold
this surprise move would come to be
known as the nixon shock
with this one announcement president
nixon effectively created our current
monetary system a system where no
currency is backed by gold or anything
of value this is what is known as a fiat
currency
fiat currency is currency that's backed
by nothing except government promises
the word fiat is a latin word and it
basically means currency that's
circulating by force
if people have confidence in that
currency and if there's enough
government force that will enable the
currency to circulate for a period of
time until people lose confidence in
their currency
money is a medium of exchange and the
way it has evolved is that it's always
something of intrinsic value until the
modern age when the politicians say well
we don't need anything of intrinsic
value anymore all we need is political
decree we can say this is money this
piece of paper is money now money has a
new characteristic but underneath it all
there's the same concept in place that
nobody ever seems to challenge and that
is that governments have a right to
declare something of of no value to be
money and you must accept it that's
really the problem and it's still the
problem today
without anything tangible backing the
currencies we use today governments
around the world have been able to issue
unlimited amounts of new currency
without restraint and with the advent of
the digital age currencies around the
world are now digits in a global banking
database
so what is bitcoin
well simply put it's a digital currency
much like the electronic currency we use
today but it's also the payment network
which facilitates the transfer of this
new digital currency from one person to
another
bitcoin is a new internet protocol that
enables the transmission of value over a
communications channel
you can think of it like being able to
send a gold coin as easily as you send
an email you can send any amount of
money to anyone in the world
any time can't be seized can't be
confiscated can't be frozen
uh very useful technology so bitcoin is
a digital currency uh and it is a
payment system um so it's a payment
system in the same way that uh bank
networks are or paypal those are those
are all payment systems but it's also a
currency so paypal and banks use the
dollar as their currency
the bitcoin payment system uses bitcoins
as its currency so they both have the
same name
what is your opinion of disruptive
digital currencies such as bitcoin if
you're looking for the idea that that a
currency doesn't really have to be
something physical it can be something
that's virtual
that's the system we already have you
know
and if you want it to be
i want a way to make payments um
electronically that's you know credit
cards i mean so exactly what it is that
this thing is supposed to be doing that
we don't already mostly do bitcoin is
different from other fiat currencies in
a couple ways
but not the way people think so most
people think it's different because it
is a digital currency but fiat
currencies are also digital right so the
dollar is a digital currency the euro is
a digital currency they're all just ones
and zeros in the banks of the world so
it's not that bitcoin is digital that
makes it unique it's unique in that it
cannot be created out of thin air
so dollars euros yen these can all be
created out of thin air by people who
have permission to do so
which is generally a central bank
bitcoin has no ability to create it out
of thin air so it is a scarce digital
asset
unlike the banking system we currently
use where bureaucrats meet behind closed
doors and determine and regulate the
supply of new currency mathematics and
cryptography are used to regulate the
creation of new bitcoins
the bitcoin network is decentralized
meaning that instead of transactions and
account balances being stored on a
central computer or database bitcoin's
ledger of accounts more commonly known
as the blockchain is distributed across
tens of thousands of computers around
the world
there's something called napster we all
remember napster we could download music
and movies from napster but after a
while it got so big and popular the
government came in shut it down because
of copyright infringements no more
napster right
so then somebody created something
called the bit torrent network what's
this this is a software people run on
their computers that allows people to
file share so if you run the software
you can go to things like pirate bay or
views or bt junkie and you can download
any music or any movies you want and
they can't stop it because it's not a
centralized location well bitcoin is the
currency that runs on the bittorrent
network
why was gold and silver considered money
for the last 4 000 years is because it
took work and effort to make that nice
beautiful coin they had to dig it out of
the ground and refine it and the
crucibles and the furnaces and stamp it
into a nice beautiful coin and that took
work so you didn't have to trust anybody
that they were going to work for you the
work was already done well bitcoin proof
of work is the same thing right you have
to hash away and solve all these math
problems you have to have the chips and
the electricity and yada yada yada to
create a bitcoin it would cost today
about 800 to make a bitcoin
i believe that bitcoin has multiple
levels of intrinsic value the properties
like being unconfiscatable
properties like this censorship
resistant value transfer that no one can
stop you from sending
more importantly what gives it intrinsic
value is the productive capacity and the
brainpower of some of the brightest
developers in the world that have chosen
to work on this open source protocol and
this productive capacity of some of the
brightest minds that are building it is
what truly gives it value
all bitcoin transactions are
cryptographically verified by thousands
of computers on the bitcoin network
these very powerful computers known as
miners expend a massive amount of energy
and processing power to verify the
integrity of each and every transaction
so the miners basically validate
transactions
all these transactions are flying around
and
they have not yet been formally vetted
by the network
if the miner believes the transactions
are valid it will
put them in the block and the block then
becomes part of the blockchain and over
time that becomes the record of truth
and so that what that means is that if
you receive bitcoin and a few blocks
happen after you receive it no one can
ever take that money away from you
because the blocks have been stuck into
the blockchain they can't be reversed
and you know that the money is
is truly yours
the decentralized nature of the bitcoin
network eliminates a single point of
failure and makes it impossible to be
hacked or to be shut down
bitcoin transactions are transmitted
peer-to-peer without the need for a
third party meaning that the user is in
complete control of their money
it's impossible to be shut down that's
the beautiful thing about it is that
there's no place there is no bitcoin
place you can't shoot bitcoin it has no
center of gravity it has no headquarters
you can't shut it down the only way you
could is to shut off the internet
your average person has absolutely no
idea how their email works but it works
and that's all that really matters and
bitcoin is very similar to that but as
far as
what i would do to tell people or
describe to people uh who don't know
about bitcoin uh what it is
i would say it's a form of money that
you can just use on your phone or your
computer in today's digital age where
everyone's on the internet uh that is
much faster to send than most of the
banks
and
it has for at least since its inception
in 2009 risen in value
for new users the inner workings of
bitcoin can be quite complex and
daunting but what's important is how
this revolutionary technology changes
how money is transferred globally
right now every single payment that you
make to another person
goes through an intermediary
either paypal or bank or visa or
mastercard and more importantly the
governmental jurisdiction
decides if you're allowed to make that
payment that payment could be stopped
halfway through and then you have to try
and get your money back
with bitcoin
no one can stop it the moment you decide
to send another person digital value
you can just send it and there's nobody
in your way there's no one that has to
give you permission to pay another
person money and all they need is an
internet connection this has the
potential to displace the need for banks
as a trust institution if you and i
exchange
currency or you know have commerce using
bitcoin and it goes on the ledger on the
blockchain we don't need a bank to
confirm that that is a valid transaction
one of the differences between bitcoin
and the banking system is the it doesn't
require a third party to perform when
you make a deposit into a checking
account or a savings account you are
actually loaning the bank your currency
they now have title to it and they have
a liability on their books to pay you
back one day but they get to do anything
they want with it and you have this
intermediary this third party
counterparty that has to perform for you
to be able to get your currency back
cryptocurrencies invert the power
structure
uh it isn't a few people at the top
controlling a whole bunch the of people
at the bottom the power goes to the
individual
in the same way that the internet
flattened access to information and
allowed anyone in the world with an
internet connection to learn basically
anything they wanted to know and to
communicate with anyone else on earth
bitcoin does that with money so now
anyone on the planet no matter their age
or the
arbitrary geographic location in which
they were born or the arbitrary rules of
the people that govern over them
that person can now
engage economically with anyone else in
the world directly
that's profoundly powerful
you do not need a bank account to
interact with bitcoin you do not need a
bank account now to receive an honest
payment from someone else in the world
and know that the money is
is legitimate and good and can't be
rescinded so money now can't be censored
any two people can send it between each
other through bitcoin
cryptocurrency bitcoin has once again
defied naysayers by spiking above 18 000
at one point today bitcoin hits a new
high we had this incredible run-up in
the fall going into the holidays and
then we've seen a pretty big pullback
this is a 30 loss in the week and a 50
loss of the year
the past year have seen the price of
bitcoin rise and fall in dramatic
fashion getting the attention of wall
street and the investment community
bitcoin is now seen by the public as a
speculative asset class that can be
traded but the core fundamentals of this
important technology cannot be
overlooked
the use of bitcoin is particularly vital
in the developing world where billions
of people are without basic banking
services
people who see the price all the time
especially in advanced societies they
focus more on the price and they think
that bitcoin is an investment solely and
that it goes up and down like a stock
based on news and expectations but the
fact is probably there's more people
in these kind of third economies they
don't own a lot but they own it and they
own it because they need it not because
they expect to get rich or hope to get
rich because they need to protect
themselves against both destroyed fiat
currencies and against capital controls
so when people think of it as an
investment they have to realize that the
reason that bitcoin's so exciting is
because it's a future money for the
world not because it's something that
could become a great investment it just
so happens to be that both can be
accomplished at the same time
one of the great powers of whether it's
bitcoin or any other cryptocurrencies if
we can figure out how to scale the
technology
we can solve a lot of problems in the
financial system we can transact with
each other globally at very low cost and
very efficiently and there's tremendous
market power in that has nothing to do
with
anyone in the financial system people
want to be able to communicate and
transact with each other
simply and quickly and the hunger to do
that is enormous
today bitcoin is seen as a financial
asset but as the technology develops the
blockchain that powers bitcoin may be
used to verify transactions other than
the transfer of money
each bitcoin is divisible into 100
millionth of a bitcoin called a satoshi
these tiny fractions of a bitcoin can be
programmed to represent assets other
than money in this way the bitcoin
blockchain can be used to verify
transactions of all kinds of items
without the need for a central authority
the bitcoin blockchain is a tremendous
technological innovation that enables
distributed consensus
people are able to come to
agreement on what the state
of
this ledger should be
and what it is
and that enables people to have trust
without
trusting
any other party or person or institution
so anywhere we need to have trust where
we need to be able to verify
what is the true and correct state of
something
that has an application
to be put on the bitcoin blockchain
for 6 000 years i've recorded history
we've always had this problem when we
want to engage in consensual exchange
that is if we're strangers can i trust
you
and what's happening with bitcoin and
the blockchain the technology that
powers bitcoin is is now possible for us
to have
trustworthy exchange without those third
parties the trust is built in through
the cryptography
that's guarantees the exchange of value
well that means that there's this
technology that is
it is as disruptive as the internet was
the publishing but this is disruptive to
these hundred different institutions
that that really are the glue that pulls
society together you know everything
from as mundane as notary publics to
the land titling to coining money
to voting
all kinds of these things are going to
be recreated in the blockchain in a way
that we will finally be able to fully
trust but what that means is what we've
seen technology do to lots of private
industries is now going to start doing
the government function the thing for me
is
understanding the implications of what
this is you can take a hundred million
bits of a bitcoin each bit is called a
satoshi right and you can program that
to be anything of value it can represent
titles to automobiles or real estate or
diamonds or gold or
votes and elections anything of value
can now be digitized and tokenized put
up on the blockchain and transacted can
be sent across the internet without
having to go through a trusted third
party
i think the blockchain and bitcoin it's
going to change the world i think it's
going to change everything in terms of
protecting people's identities
allowing people to own property bitcoins
for the 2 billion people that don't have
bank accounts the 5 billion people that
can't prove they exist they don't have
title to real estate and stuff that's
what bitcoin is going to change the most
for those people is because you know
they're going to jump from the third
world to the first world it's really
going to revolutionize latin america
africa southeast asia
where people can finally now own real
estate we can have a transparent
election that can't be hacked imagine
that's gonna change the world in and of
itself
tempers are beginning to flare
these people have already been in queue
for more than three hours now carrying
currency notes the government suddenly
backed on tuesday night
because anyone can start using bitcoin
by simply installing an app on their
phone
bitcoin can be used by the developing
world to protect their wealth from
unstable currencies and government
control
we're seeing it behave as a crisis
currency in venezuela in uh nigeria in
zimbabwe when these countries can't get
a grasp on their own monetary policy
people flood to bitcoin
the fate of the unbanked and underbanked
population
no longer lies in the hands of corrupt
governments
centrally planned economies and central
banks
it really there's a new option a plan b
personally i live in the united states
and a lot of people in the us get bank
accounts very easily have credit cards
debit cards and all of that and they
don't find that there are too many
frictions and pain points but in a
country like india there are 233 million
individuals who are unbanked who don't
have access to a traditional financial
infrastructure and so they're operating
cash payment to cash payment but bitcoin
has become a game changer so individuals
and lessons can hold on to it they can
spend it they can transfer it
internationally there are so many use
cases
currently bitcoin transactions can
sometimes carry a significant fee making
it unsuitable for use for small
transactions
but bitcoin is programmable money
meaning that new layers and technologies
can be integrated into it
in the near future one such development
called the lightning network will help
reduce the cost of bitcoin transactions
at the moment bitcoin is actually
suffering from
being too popular
one of the challenges that bitcoin has
is every transaction
needs computational power to process so
at the moment bitcoin can settle about
four to seven transactions a second
and in the future each of those four to
seven transactions a second
can contain
a million transactions within it
and that's what the second layer and
lightning is trying to do
it will just make it so much more
efficient and so much cheaper for the
average person
the integration of the lightning network
into the bitcoin protocol will scale
bitcoin into a fast cheap and efficient
payment system
once implemented this will have enormous
implications for the developing
one of the stumbling blocks to doing
international business is the payment
system and to be honest if you're taking
credit cards from some countries
the
those countries are so associated with
fraud
that your your rates on all credit cards
you take just become astronomical and it
becomes prohibitive
something like 33 of the credit card
transactions coming out of africa are
fraudulent so nobody wants to take
business from africa it's just too risky
with bitcoin you know the funds are good
so as a merchant yeah pay with bitcoin
also anything you want you know that's
legal to africa that has tremendous
implications you know to be able to get
access to these types of products and
services so seamlessly
and
then they're able to start having
property rights
and property rights is really what's
going to help lift them up out of
poverty
closer to home in today's digital world
governments have started to phase out
cash replacing it with digital currency
in this environment where concerns over
personal privacy are very real bitcoin
provides monetary sovereignty outside
the control of government policy
when you have a situation where the
government is trying to control they
don't want people to have the means of
hiding anything from them not just from
a tax standpoint they want to know what
everyone's doing in big brother fashion
so you know the way that i look at
bitcoin is it's the ultimate monetary
weapon that the people have never had in
history
every government in the world wants to
go cashless one of the reasons is that
in a cashless society you are not able
to exit the banking system when people
panic they run to the atm machines they
run to the bank and they withdraw money
the other thing is the governments are
starting to run out of money and
governments don't build anything they
just use other people's money so they
are treating everyone as a tax evader
i believe the main reason why bitcoin is
so popular and important
is not because
of its finite supply and being gold
it's because of anti-money laundering
laws preventing people from doing what
they want with their money one of the
main functions of government is to
create currency
and
bitcoin is
successful only because of its potential
for circumvention
uh
lack of oversight so it seems to me it
ought to be outlawed uh it doesn't serve
any socially useful function
as to whether or not bitcoin
is is illegal or should be seen to be
illegal
cash has been used for a whole heck of a
lot more illegal things that bitcoin has
through the years and still is today
uh cash is untraceable
uh it's easily transportable nobody
knows where that dollar has been and how
it's been moved from hand to hand to
hand
so it's just a matter of making that
connection that a cryptocurrency is
really not a new thing
it's just a different version and a
digital form of something that's existed
in our society and legal structures for
millennia
bitcoin is shifting the paradigm and
challenging the legacy financial system
recently jamie dimon chairman and ceo of
jpmorgan chase america's largest bank
was quoted calling bitcoin a fraud
why is bitcoin a fraud here's the reason
governments the first thing they do is
form a currency
they like to control the currency they
control it through a central bank they
also like to know who has it
where it is where it's going
wait until someone gets hurt wait until
it's used for illicit purposes which is
somewhat useful listed purposes they
close it down you got people like jamie
dimon a serious guy calling it a fraud
um
you mean like there was hundreds of
billions of dollars in securities that
jamie dimon sold the public a decade ago
called more tobacco securities he's
calling bitcoin a fraud is that going to
go to zero like his securities that he
sold the public
you know first first with respect to
asking a banker about whether they like
bitcoin or not that's kind of like
asking a king do you like democracy it's
just so thoroughly frustrating and
insulting when people who know very
little about what we do watch an
up-and-coming technology and have the
audacity to call us all criminals
you know we're not the criminals here
the whole damn reason this ecosystem
exists is because they're the criminals
and
you know it doesn't really matter at
this point what he thinks the genie's
out of the bottle somebody in this room
or somebody at this conference or
somebody around the world is going to
solve the problem with decentralized
lending and value stable currencies and
decentralized exchange and within five
to ten years banks will become less and
less relevant just like landline
telephones are becoming less and less
relevant we're going to wake up one day
we're going to be in charge of our own
money and jamie dimon in retirement can
watch the world as it is not the world
as he would like it to be
the bitcoin blockchain is built on
decentralized consensus outside the
control of a central party however with
the hype in the rise of cryptocurrencies
such as bitcoin both central banks and
commercial banks have started to develop
their own digital currencies under the
guise of what they call blockchain
technology
my big fear is that what is going to
happen
is blockchain technology will be adopted
by uh governments and fiat national
currencies will be uh run on blockchain
technologies and and the entire sys the
whole monetary system globally will
eventually become cashless
and at that point if it's centralized
and there's an entity that runs the
blockchain they can lock you out of it
if they don't like what you're doing and
they can trace everything that you do
every transaction everywhere you go will
be recorded and so uh you know if we're
not careful this has the ability to
enslave us or free us
i think blockchain
or any kind of open ledger distributive
database will have a tremendous impact
on our world
my fear is that and this is used to
centralize
digital technology
gives a banker the ability to put a chip
in you
to tax you whenever they want to
interface with a money system with you
physically and to perfect the collateral
so i love the innovation and the
question for all of this is
how can we innovate and make the
financial system more efficient
and do it in a way
at the same time
where we
we
distribute the power lines in the
political system the blockchain is a
technology which is a good technology we
actually use it it will be useful a lot
of different things god bless blockchain
cryptocurrencies and digital currencies
i think are also fine you know jp moore
moves six trillion of dollars around the
world every day we don't do it in cash
it's done digitally if it can be done
digitally with the blockchain so be it
but it'll still be a dollar crypto
currency
a majority of the people are using the
word blockchain and they don't really
care
whether it has this decentralized mining
the government is going to just have a
digital representation of the dollar
they can call it a blockchain but
there's not going to be mining there's
not going to be decentralization it's
going to be a centralized coin whether
they call it a blockchain or not is
irrelevant
the whole purpose of a blockchain is to
remove control from a central party if
you're a a central bank and you make a
blockchain for dollars and then you have
dollar coin
if you still have full control over the
dollar coin you can create how much of
it you want you can control where it
goes
there was no point in having a
blockchain at all you might as well just
have a centralized database like a
banking system
to really use blockchains in any
meaningful way it it means that there is
no person in charge and so a central
bank by definition is the one who is
supposed to be in charge of money and
thus they would never uh create a
blockchain or a cryptocurrency that they
couldn't control
so that's why they will likely be made
redundant because the market can choose
what kind of money it uses and it now
has a choice between
a digital currency that can be
controlled by central parties and
inflated without limit or a digital
currency that cannot be controlled by
any central party and that has a fixed
amount and can't be debased
over time that's going to be a very
obvious choice
bitcoin and the blockchain behind it are
incredibly powerful technologies
as the future unfolds these technologies
could be used to restructure the
financial system into one of fairness
and equality for all a system outside
the control of the banking elite
we have millions of people now taking an
interest in
what is money the question of what is
money what should it be
and they're learning
especially a lot of young people
precious metals were once money then
came the era of paper money could we now
be entering a golden age of
decentralized digital money
only time will tell
bitcoin is first and foremost about
changing how the financial system of the
planet operates
uh however bitcoin is also a financial
asset itself and it goes through these
bubbles and people have made many
millions of dollars
when they buy it low and then it goes up
in value but that's not really what
matters at all what matters is that it's
actually going to change the entire
ecosystem of the planet how all humans
interact with each other and that's a
very exciting thing to be part of
[Music]
you